and welcome back to the Leia Heil pen
show so today I'm bringing you back one
of my favorite guests and somebody who
you guys have been asking for before I
bring him on please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe so you
never miss a video
welcome to the show sneako welcome back
one of the favorite guests I didn't know
this was requested to to happen again
yeah we went super viral yeah did we
yeah what did like everything like
because we I've seen everything just go
super viral yeah I guess there's good
back and forth they like you a lot of my
stream too they've been asking to have
you back but I don't know sometimes it's
like you're very protective Gideon the
manager and everything it's like very
the way you curate the image and
everything is really I don't know I just
come on I just uh all day on Twitter I'm
always streaming it's just I don't
really think about that stuff too much I
just say stuff online but you're like
professional old school with it which is
good yeah well that's all Gideon yeah
that's what my brother because he just
like handles everything
um so that I can remain feminine and
nice and sweet like genuinely this is
like how we curate everything that's
good you need to have somebody to
protect that image you were telling a
story can you tell that story about what
happened this morning in uh in Brickell
oh yeah so so yeah we were chatting
earlier obviously um I was walking
around Brickell in the morning and um
some guy just came comes out to me and
he's like really weird he doesn't and
I'm walking with Gideon and he doesn't
even look at Gideon and he goes straight
to me
um
are you Leia is that you and Gideon
straight away is just like stop no don't
speak to her and we just keep on walking
so like I don't even have to do anything
or get any you know I don't have to like
fight or anything like that he just he
just deals with it so it's pretty good
it's nice I like having the the
masculine energy around to you know
protect the lady you know yeah you
mentioned something before I think on my
stream about how he's kind of set the
standard for how your husband has to be
because if your husband cannot compare
to that if he's there like no that
protective uh brotherly nature that he
has if your husband can't do the same
thing then you're just gonna be like my
brother's like I know how you can't
you're pathetic I know it's a problem
actually every time Guinea and I are
walking he's and I'll see about the
other day he's constantly like lecturing
me like he's telling me something you
know the world is like this Leia do you
know where dogs come from you know dogs
are actually like this and each dog is
bred for this reason I'm just there like
oh my God here's another lecture but
actually I think I think I need that I
need to be walking with like a man who
knows more than me and can teach to be
more and can can you know set the
standards so yeah Gideon Gideon's ruined
everything I haven't noticed a lot of
brother-sister relationships like that
are you the who's the Elder between the
two he is okay that makes sense I have
an uh an elder sister and she doesn't
even at this point I'm 24 she only sees
me as like little bro to this day she's
still like did you eat you know did you
call this make sure you're driving
carefully stuff like and she's only two
years older and we're never gonna have a
conversation where I'm gonna know
something more than her because it's
just not it's not possible in her brain
how old is she 20 26 26 well I think it
will flip it'll flip because that's like
when you're 30 and she's 32. I don't
think it's ever gonna I think it's gonna
flip now I noticed that even like when
my grandma talks to my mom it's always
that same thing too like did you eat did
you same thing no matter what it like my
dad's almost 60 and his mom always still
talks to him like he's a kid yeah I
don't think that Dynamic will ever
change no I think It's Gonna Change I
think it's Gonna Change give it a little
bit of time because like right now you
are younger and obviously women mature
faster than men so right now like
mentally younger emotionally you're
younger but I think I think it's gonna
flip you'll know more about the world at
some point like she'll her intelligence
I think and all the families are
probably gonna like jump on me right now
but I think we'll like plateau in a way
when she becomes more like focused on
family and kids and husband like she's
not going to be
I don't know like developing her mind as
quickly as she would perhaps when she
was younger everyone's going to kill me
for that but does that make sense you
see what I mean but I think that if you
grow up feminist I don't even think it
you're capable of like even if you start
to explain that immediately he's
mansplaining he doesn't know I'm
triggered this is problematic there's
just all these roadblocks that they set
up to prevent a woman from even being
able to understand a different
perspective especially from your brother
from your younger brother I don't see
you're like uh your sign when you hear
that but at least you're so open-minded
enough to to hear it out I don't even
think I think it just like it's just
noise
from somebody a racist misogynistic
incel well you've been going super fast
certainly um even more viral with like
Twitter and everything
um how have you been finding all of that
because you you get people saying I know
you showed me a tweet somebody said I
hate you with all my heart
that's a lot yeah uh Twitter's been it's
been good to post videos on there again
and it's been like I think my the most
mainstream platform that I have
uh besides Rumble obviously which is but
that's an alternative platform
it's it's
so how is it seeing all the hate um
I'm used to it at this point it's just
like part of my it helps me like
psychoanalyze the world and actually I'm
starting to realize like the the
hierarchy of like why people if you just
look look at look at someone's profile
you could figure out why they hate
somebody else very quickly like if you
hate me or you hate fresh and fit or you
hate Tate or you hate anybody with like
a similar ideology or people that hate
you you probably have I could guess it
already you tweet about how like who is
Ice spice I swear to God I'd never heard
of Thai Spice whatever she's she's a New
York rapper okay when you tweet
something like that you get a lot of
those like the ghetto feminists
um girl boss Queens single mom stuff
like that who are really upset about you
because you are the polar opposite of
that's a different life path that they
didn't take and you're representing
something that's completely opposite to
them and then deep down there's a sense
of jealousy there's a there's comparison
and so instead of admitting that they
choose to hate you the same thing with
me like people who say who hate me who
invest their lives into trying to make
call me insecure to try to invalidate my
masculinity and stuff like that if you
look at their page you look at what they
talk about you can always figure it out
people who are on the same page about
what I believe and when it comes to
um certain you know I don't want to say
I'm going to get you a strike but who
are on the same page let's just say
politically yes medically yeah medically
we got you right yeah if you're on the
same page about that then they
understand where I'm coming from and my
intentions and what I want to do and
I've been thinking a lot about this if
you have good intentions
if most people weren't brainwashed they
would want people like me to succeed
they would want people who they would
want strong men to succeed not saying
I've never called myself an alpha male I
don't think I am but there's the pursuit
of that and so people should be
supporting like yeah this is how you
become the best version of yourself
because strong men need to lead Society
they need to be in charge there's a
reason why the patriarchy exists
matriarchy has never worked before and
if people believe that and they believed
in the good of humanity and they
actually analyze what's going on they
would say that that's the biggest
problem is that strong men are not
leading and so in seeing the active
Pursuit and me trying to be the best
person that I could possibly be
they'd be like this is what you need to
I thank you for doing this and here's
how you can be better but their way of
doing it because they can't analyze it
properly is to try to belittle me and
bring you down and I just see that as as
like [__] tests I see that as different
tests like when you're when you're on a
date with a girl and she's gonna be like
oh you really think you're all this what
she's really saying No this is this is a
really common thing right it's really
common yeah
girls would be like it's little things
I'm sure you've done it all the time too
I've never gone to man oh you think
you're all that because you're not even
you're not even aware of it you're not
even aware it's just in your nature like
when when a guy sits down and then
you're asking him about his medical
history for example and you're like
that's that's a [__] test you're trying
to see are you strong enough to be able
to avoid of course a different voice
telling you what you should do with your
body correct right and so you're testing
him you're trying to see if he's capable
of leading and I noticed that not even
so that same Dynamic you see on a date I
see from
these liberal soy boys from people who
just talk without any specific message
online from the people who you know they
have a lot of insecurities have a lot of
and just just talk
they are [__] testing like a woman would
on a date by constantly saying I hate
you I hate you I hate you that's them
like are you really a man capable of
being right no you're not there must be
something wrong with you and so they
should test you the same way so I I
don't even take that hate seriously just
my point is that it's just them trying
to find reasons why they shouldn't
listen to you you know if I'm trying to
be if I have a lot of followers and
technically I'm leading people and I'm
trying to spread truth that's that's a
leadership role they're trying to find
reasons why I'm incapable of that and I
understand that because you know there's
there's a lot of reasons why that should
be questioned but it's so weird because
you can say such obvious things and
people just find something to say and
that's something I've only recently
noticed because I tweeted today about um
Kanye West because his daughter's been
doing that thing with ice spice I don't
know so I basically said like that's
Kanye's fault because like if you have
children with a ratchet woman you're
gonna have a ratchet child like have
like you should pick a woman who you
want your daughter to become like I will
pick a man who I want my sons to come
right so if you have a if you have a
daughter with Kim Kardashian your
daughter's going to end up like Kim
Kardashian you're right and everybody
commented like coming from a woman who
doesn't have children what are you
talking about did I'm like how do you
need to have kids like nobody in my 20s
give me give me a minute number two like
how like how do you even need how do you
need to have children to know that I
don't understand how you can just
disagree with me like wouldn't don't you
want to pick a quality individual like
why would you marry a woman who became
famous from a sex tape like how is that
controversial I was singing the same
exact thing and actually when I was uh
working on yay 24 that was part of the
conversation he had come back from a
conversation with Donald Trump and Trump
had mentioned that
you he was basically criticizing yay he
was saying like he was just calling Kim
Kardashian names and stuff like that I
don't want to repeat them and yeah his
response like well this is the mother of
my children so I understand like and
he's been very public about this too I'm
not trying to say anything disrespectful
about yay but he had a porn addiction
since he was six and so I've been
thinking about that same subject yeah
because he was six he found oh my God
I'm sure he's talked about this publicly
but I wouldn't know uh he found a box of
porn that his dad had in his house or
something like that he started watching
porn when he was six years old and then
that kind of shaped his view of women
and probably turned him into more of a
sex addict than he would have been if
that never happened and you can hear it
a lot of his lyrics he'll say things
like uh I think I just fell in love with
the porn star got married in the
bathroom and then got divorced by the
end of the night and then three years
later he married a porn star yeah um and
I'd say I don't think and I was thinking
a lot about that because I think yay is
a pure soul
but you could see how a lot of the
degeneracy of the West corrupted him and
it wasn't his fault so at six years old
becomes a sex addict because
accidentally he steps upon his dad's box
of porn and his dad has a box of porn
because maybe he's in a marriage that is
unsatisfied so he needs so he has this
thing and as a result he marries a woman
who people perceive as a porn star
because of his addictions as a kid and
then he has kids with her and now do you
see the cycle continues his children are
in Tick Tock even though Tick Tock is is
terrible for children they shouldn't be
on there they shouldn't be dancing to
sexual songs especially at that age and
you don't need kids on there there's
just no reason for them to be making
those videos they can have fun they
don't need to post it on the internet
they don't need to have more eyes on
them I think it's disgusting so I
understand his his criticism of that and
of um of Kim's of her mothering
qualities
but you have to see that at the same
time like this is what happens when you
you marry porn star but and I was
thinking that but that's that's the
level deeper can you really even blame
him for marrying a porn star when he yes
because he's a grown man and so he has
to he like I'm sorry what happened to
him as a child but once you hit like
dude once you hit 30 and you're a man
you know you better sort that stuff out
how do you sort that out like can you
really change what you're attracted to
can you really that's something that's
innate and see say if he married a
traditional woman who's perfect and
everything like that and he has this sex
addiction that was that's not his fault
he's going to find other way he's going
to find a mistress like being a porn
addicted means you're attracted to a
certain imagery it's like maybe he saw
that porn video and like that was or you
see him on the cover of a magazine I
think he said that when you saw her on a
shoot that's when he fell in love with
her like seeing her as an image first
you know but he's a grown adult so it's
like
okay you're attracted to that you
thought you thought you saw her in a
porn shoot you thought that was amazing
okay great but now think about your
children and what that means you know
like you have to think ahead in the long
term like I could for example I could
marry a vaccinated man because I think
he's just so attractive and I'm like wow
I saw you and I just I've never seen
anything better but I think about my
children that I would have with this
person I'm like hang on you know they
could have heart issues they could have
health issues so now I'm like um maybe I
gotta look somewhere else
but overall I just see it as a as a
result of the the degeneracy of the West
yeah the it's it's porn it's the music
industry it's attention economy it's the
Celebrity Status like all this has ended
up to his daughter being on Tick Tock
and he doesn't want that to happen the
fact that we don't respect fathers
anymore and yay is a good father and
many people just say that he's too
controlling for wanting his daughter to
not be on Tick Tock it's the result of
all these problems in the west
um and a lot of this is solved by
religion a lot of this is solved by
Islam and a pure Christian Nation which
America isn't America does not have does
not hold Christian values anymore but I
saw glimpses of that in Dubai how that
could be run properly but at the same
time have you been to Dubai I only spent
like five days there so I don't know
enough about it but tell me I know you
just came back from Dubai so how was it
I'm about to go again tomorrow night oh
wow from another couple days that's
amazing we got you just in time perfect
wait so you just came back so how was
the buy well I went to Dubai and I just
came from I was just shooting a short
film in New Jersey for seven days I'm
here for two days and then oh wow
constantly and I'm going to Japan right
after oh my God non-stop emotion right
now wait so let's start with with Dubai
how was that what do you actually do a
bunch of different
um podcasts yeah I see you have a new
Rolex yeah he got me this Rolex that's
amazing can I see it yeah let me see
yeah let me take it off
I'm like yanking you come closer I want
to see first Rolex let me see and shout
out to Sartorius shooter Jewel for
getting me the the band it's that the
Jubilee band it's really nice
what's the what does jubilee mean like
um I don't know that's a London word you
guys know that Gideon knows go and get
you want to tell us this is Gideon the
manager hello everyone so yeah Jubilee I
think that's just the type of bracelet
you know what if it has a gold thing
here does that because I like that's
just two-tone yeah you got Jubilee
oyster bracelet presidential bracelet
this is beautiful stunning Muslims can't
wear gold so I need to keep it like this
no we can't I didn't know that yeah I
need to ask my my friend munia about
that I didn't know that more jewelry you
can't wear jewelry no I took off my no
I'm still wearing it you're still
wearing wait wait Muslims call my
jewelry no I didn't know that why do you
have to be like like pure and without
and because it's like worshiping you can
wear jewelry yeah right I was just like
flashy shiny stuff on you that's gay
what about women women yeah women women
can oh yeah woman could be gay no so
women can wear jewelry yeah but men
can't men can't I didn't know that
so wait so so Dubai it was it was good
so a man got your Rolex that's so nice
and I did all these podcasts we went on
a I was there with fresh and fit and we
basically went on a tour
um to clear Tate's name and to spread
the positive messages and keep that
message alive because you see the amount
of hate right now it's very popular to
hate on them especially when they're in
jail and they can't defend themselves
um especially when people thought that
he had cancer did you see all the people
like celebrating it's incredible like
how demonic most people on social media
are and I I want everybody who does that
because that happened to me I I had uh I
was doing a movie last summer and I had
like blood makeup all over me and then
people thought that I got beat up people
were like celebrating on Twitter like
people were posting like yeah
celebration memes all this stuff you
should be you should have to post a
picture of your face and your ID in
order to celebrate somebody else's
downfall that's when I'm like I want to
know your name your whole government
name before you say something like
before you wish on somebody oh no your
mother's name your father's name I want
to know where you live
your place of birth I'm not gonna show
up at your house but you should have
that responsibility you shouldn't be
able to hide behind a burner account to
prey on somebody's death right and the
amount of people who are celebrating uh
the this this conspiracy that Tate had
cancer I was discussing and you know
these people should be remembered so we
just we were there doing all these
podcasts either the Tom Collins podcast
this is a shirt from his gem oh nice um
we still have a couple more coming out
but just uh to you know spread positive
message right now when when they're in
jail and they're they're completely
innocent and they've been just nobody
actually believes that they're people do
rationally believe it they're they're
they're coping look at everybody look we
you could see the pattern just simple
pattern recognition you see everybody
who thinks that blue hair fat depressed
stay them in therapy all everything
vegan Apple watch you know like it's
it's a pat it's like you
yeah
he watches my one
I will debunk the Apple watch Myth very
very soon
yes mechanical watches are greater than
exactly digital watches Samsung Apple
watch but we'll talk about that no I
mean they're just pudgy bodies blue hair
they them they don't actually think that
he's guilty they just need him to be to
validate their entire world to you and
they know it I have so many questions
right now wait okay hang on speaking of
blue hair I have a question and we're
gonna get back to tape but Destiny
firstly who is that he's uh and he's
done videos of me and I haven't even
watched it because I I just can't be
bothered yeah he hates you yeah does he
okay sorry so okay so Destiny is as far
as I know is he wants to debate you so
bad I don't know who he is it doesn't
matter he's a gamer he's like uh 34 and
he games all day and uh he likes to
debate online he hates me I didn't know
he existed I didn't know he existed I
swear like so he asked me if I can get a
debate with you but I'm like oh my God
she's like nah don't do it it's just
it's gonna nah see that see that's
really nice it's like you protected me
you protected me from like this is crazy
that's gonna make you yeah no don't no
it's not worth it that's good but okay
so like who who is he and why is his
hair blue because that's I mean why
that's what he is
haired feminists he's a feminist yeah
okay blue arid believes in trans people
he believes interest quadruple
vaccinated Biden it's just everything
like all of it all of it so you did a
tweet saying that his wife is in your DM
so basically this was yesterday and I
actually saw it I read it and I looked
her up and then I went on to Instagram
and then I was like I thought you were
just joking and then I went over to his
sister I was like oh wow they're
actually together is that legit is his
wife hatching your DMs or is it
Photoshop they have an open relationship
which um you know I've tried before
doesn't work it's not don't do it I
don't recommend that for anybody and his
wife has been messaging me
she actually yeah I mean I told you it
was real because I showed my brother I
showed Gideon and I was like is the
screenshot real I mean I know them
um and I had like the you know it's this
is a touchy subject because actually I
like the guy I'm not gonna lie I
disagree with him about everything I
think he's uh I think because he
believes in free speech but he's
actually willing to have open
conversation which is extremely
important so at least he's willing to
challenge his ideas most of them aren't
but I like him and contest actually
before I tweeted that I sent it to him
I'm like would you mind oh you did well
first even before I thought about
tweeting it I sent him this because like
that's his wife and I'm like your wife
is texting me and he's like LOL you guys
should do a collab I'm like what
do that blue you know how many this this
is like a week of me stewing like I was
having bad dreams about this I was
thinking like his wife and like bro like
I've I've hung out with them sometimes
like I go on I go get dinner with
Destiny and stuff wait what are you what
what do you talk about with this guy uh
we just debate yeah we debate and we've
went rock climbing and stuff together
like I I consider I consider him a
friend but then some he's like well you
barely know me so I guess I don't know
it's like whatever but so I I'm suing
all night thinking about this thing and
I sent it to him because I asked all
these other people all these older men
I'm like what do I do about this some of
them I'm not gonna name names they're
like should [__] his wife because
they're like [__] that guy [__]
really and I'm like no and no it's just
too weak and then I asked other people
like you should tell a man to man you
know I've been trying to be more of a
wholesome like God-fearing person so I'm
like let me not go rush to Twitter
that's what the Liberals would do the
Liberals would immediately like look at
this and just like post a DM so first I
showed him and that he didn't care
and it's like you should do a collab
that's that's the um as a woman I would
be so offended if my man didn't care
like I would be so offended my brother
said to me he was like Leia when you get
married your husband may not want you to
have the podcast so I was like oh really
why and he was like well you know you
know you do sit down with men for an
hour and you look into each other's eyes
for a very long time and get to know
each other and they teach you stuff and
I was like hmm yeah I guess you may not
want me to that makes sense fair enough
and so now I'm like
I'm glad that my husband wouldn't want
me to have a podcast
like I'm happy because I want to be
protected yeah like I like otherwise I'd
be very uncomfortable if my husband's
happy with me to like go speak with men
for hours and and all this stuff like no
you should look at me that's my woman
like I own her she shouldn't be with all
these men like ah
I don't understand how how is his wife
like okay with this he's gonna win
that's that's just they they live a
completely opposite lifestyle um to
everything like that
um and then I sent him the two
beforehand like would you mind he said
yeah sure go that's nice of you so but
yeah that's for for the family because
they were like like his face like it was
just cause a whole [__] storm on Twitter
but yeah you know a lot of it is just
like I see it asparing mental sparring
between like two friends you know I I I
genuinely like the guy stuff like that I
don't think I would ever beef with him
really but it's good to have somebody
like because we're talking so
confidently about our worldview right
now oh I know isn't it so funny it just
seems like this is this is reality this
is the way it is right and then to have
somebody who's like no like complete on
the opposite and willing to back up the
points I think it's healthy to have that
because
obviously the truth is somewhere in the
middle it's got to be somewhere in the
but maybe not I don't know I don't know
do you know what I just I just see how
crazy the world is becoming and like
everything is a slippery slope right
like the whole lgbtq plus plus that goes
on for years right like it's such a
slippery slope because at first it's
like if somebody wants to identify as a
man but they're actually a woman you
know each to their own if that's how you
feel happy for sure do it but then we
get down the slippery slope where it's
like well hang on what if a grown man
wants to identify as a child and now we
have a problem whatever right and they
do grown man going to kids parks wearing
diapers it's disgusting identifying as
babies it's a mental disorder and now
they're allowed a men to compete in
women's powerlifting competitions
um you see videos every day of men
preventing their kids from even starting
puberty because like I'm not going to
raise a man I'm not going to raise a
male so they give a three-year-old
puberty blockers which is uh just child
abuse so now we're seeing like real life
problems limbs as a result of this let's
begin right I was in atheist for a long
time and I remember when the gay
marriage thing came up and I'm like this
would be better to get married so was I
[__] just stupid like in the trans
people like people could cut their dicks
off if they want to and then all the
religious people were like no this is
God warned us about this they said it in
the Bible they were like hold up signs
pray for Jesus Jesus and I'm like these
guys are like crazy because they're like
whatever man they were right look at the
slippery slope that they were warning us
about it happened it went too far and it
started because we started allowing
gay marriage
we went down there I I agree with you
like with the whole like gay marriage
thing I'm very like look each to their
own I don't wanna I don't wanna impinge
on anybody else's life because I am a
freedom maximalist I just don't like
when things become unethical and immoral
and when children are involved and then
that's where like that slippery slope
leads to like the term Love Is Love Is A
Dangerous slippery slope because like if
love is love then why can't
a 50 year old man be with a 10 year old
girl because love is love well no so you
see what I mean like these slippery
slopes is like my biggest Sweden or the
Netherlands I don't remember which
country maybe someone could fact check
me but they just allowed bestiality in
Europe they allowed bestiality in Europe
well yeah not in all of Europe but they
do in one country I don't remember what
it is they decriminalized bestiality
probably the Netherlands I don't know I
think it's the Netherlands should we do
like a Joe Rogan thing Gideon can you
fact check that real quick can you [__]
can you pull that up for us tell tell
the story of what happened today when we
were looking at apartment oh yeah
take a mic
so to diffuse
I was looking at some real estate in
Miami today and this is when you can use
the woke things to your benefit so
basically he took us back through the
mail changing room to get to the main
lobby and then he goes oh
Leia's not allowed in here obviously
because Leia is a woman so I said to the
realtor oh no don't worry she's
transgender I literally said it straight
she's transgender and then the guy was
just looked at me like oh okay yeah like
no do I wouldn't dare want to step on
that no no so you can use these woke
things to your benefit that's all about
how it's all about negotiating and
navigating through the Matrix you've got
to understand how to go through the
Matrix
um and using the work things and then
that's when you fully like accomplish
like that's when you're at like expert
level of me you know how to communicate
with Bots yeah yeah you're right that's
really funny how to speak yeah I speak
fluent by it oh you do yeah I'm really
good at it like how do you Gideon does
really flip that's toxic oh you did I
can't believe he would say that oh wow
yeah I don't I don't know if I like this
you're harassing me please stop I'm
triggered that's so good that's so good
there was one uh so it's a bill proposed
in Spain uh zoophilia May soon become
decriminalized it's not yet but there
was uh yeah so that's a shame the
Spanish are usually quite traditional
and quite you know that's why I like
Miami because we have like the Spanish
here the Hispanic you know yeah they
look quite no no no but still but still
the Spanish and the Hispanics are quite
like traditional and in that in their
gender roles and like but they Spain and
Italy were the countries to show the
lockdown more than their leaders because
that's the European Union and they're a
bunch of lunatics and we have to tear
them down yeah
but um it's funny because we're looking
for apartments for Gideon my brother
congrats on the move thank you thank you
I have to talk like this
a move that I'm here in Miami I love
Miami I'm considering La maybe I should
come in yeah I'm considering la oh
electric shock but probably but I think
I'm gonna go for Miami and La is too
woke unless you're hidden in the Hills
you go down to Beverly Hills in West
Hollywood you do the business there you
have fun and you hide away back up in
the hills but I think Miami is probably
the place yeah Miami's probably the
place for me yeah yeah LA's trash well
yeah Gideon's really good at navigating
work people and he like drops like jokes
and he'll be like does this building
have any like rainbow Flags he's like
how many Rainbow Flags otherwise like
otherwise I can't live here and then
like they they don't any what flags
rainbow Flags oh okay and then they're
like they're like oh welcome to Miami
how come you've moved here and and he's
just like oh London had too many Rainbow
Flags like just so nonchalant about
about it you know what I mean and it's
catch them off guard well but they don't
really know oh they don't really like
they don't really like getting shot but
I'm not in shot okay don't worry tell
the story and maybe I'll come late yeah
well no I'm just saying like tell the
story of all the jokes I drop about yeah
like rainbow Flags I know it's just
really impressive he's just like walking
around like you know oh there's too many
Rainbow flags and I'm like oh God Gideon
just leave it and then he's like and
then he's like um yeah I don't like this
apartment it feels a bit matrixy and I'm
like kitty like what like how are you
like you're just so so nonchalant with
these people I I can't even get involved
in it for me it's a headache
oh yeah Gideon's like oh yeah I'm like
because obviously you have the Metro
mover in Miami they sell him the
apartment because he's like oh yeah the
train is right there and he's just like
oh I don't take the train of two Matrix
see I only take Ubers I don't say train
it's like the confidence that he has
with like [__] on all these things
yeah yeah it's pretty impressive yeah I
got I noticed that too when I was doing
this movie shoot I think uh
what would they say they had some ladies
like living in her van and she's acting
and she's doing auditions and I was just
like talking really openly about
um the the jab and stuff like that and
she's like are you like one of those
like Q Anon conspiracy theorists like
yeah what's q and on it's just some
Facebook psyop they they whenever
there's a conspiracy theory they put
something else to distract people to
make you look crazy to distract from the
truth but what is Q Anon it's just like
these deep like you remember like pizza
gate or like you know about adrenochrome
there's they're always it's just a crazy
Facebook yeah okay that go too far with
it oh yeah they use that so then people
are like oh you're like a crazy Q Anon
person like no I'm just trying to warn
you that you're gonna get a blood clot
okay really casual you're gonna get
blood clot yeah well speaking of like
speaking of the echo chamber this is
actually a pretty wild story I have for
you so I'm supposed to be doing a TV oh
I am doing a TV show
um in a month in La thanks which is
talking about crypto it's been really
fun and um the producers are super cool
love them shout out to the weight token
love these people
um but they DM me and they were like
just warning you when you come on set
the production company are all based in
LA and
um they know who you are and you know
you might get some side eyes you might
get some side eyes you know they they
they were all like what why are you
having her on the show
and um and they were like don't worry we
love you we want you on the show and you
know the the head of production he he
understands why you're there and you
know and even though I'm a woman yeah
you know I'm a minority okay
that's good thank you I'm a woman okay
and I'm talking about crypto you know
that should be good and it's not good
enough right so yeah wait there's a
crypto show and people are not base
but it's the it's the production company
I know I know how are you how are you in
crypto we talk about decentralizing you
believe in all this centralized nonsense
no I don't know
yeah so what so the people in yeah the
people in web 3 and nfts are woke as
hell like they are so woke because they
come to it with this mentality of like
equal opportunity anyone can get in no
you know no barriers to entry yeah
that's very L.A that's why I don't
recommend it at all like the fact that
they can't even see you know what's
gonna happen on the show oh no they're
not even going to confront you at all
about your beliefs they're gonna like go
research your Twitter every night
and then on shoot all day this is them
just yeah I know side eye what's it it
was funny because Gideon's coming with
me yeah so it's like good luck like I'm
gonna be there like just super Focus
like chilling whatever and getting's
gonna be there
I saw your side eyes I swear I swear if
someone brings up if someone tries to go
it's cute aren't you Leia you're the one
who I'm like no stop excuse use me not
the time and the place back off we're
working can't you see if you have an
issue talk to production they hired us
we're here for a reason go away trust me
trust me no one is going to start
anything on this set because
I will kick up such a fuss that they'll
hear it in [__] Miami I'm telling you
so then why we got you we got you it's
all good well good luck though la is uh
it's a garbage place
I think the last time I was really
thinking like this is the Matrix I was
in LA and I was waiting for an Uber and
the first one canceled because I didn't
have a mask and this happened like two
months ago she's like like literally
it's in 2023 wow like mask I'm like and
I almost got in and put it on I'm like
no she drives off so I'm standing there
waiting on the corner calling the other
Uber I'm like this is clown world and
then there's one there's a witchcraft
like astrology which nose piercing sign
over there where they can come in and do
witchcraft on your palms and stuff over
there there's a they them bald mullet
with blue hair walking over with the
giant belly there's these like half
gender people walking there and I'm like
this is this is the center of the mate
I'm here I'm in it right now I saw all
of it in just three seconds that is why
I can't do it like there's witchcraft
there's a mask and then there's some guy
shooting fentanyl in his arm and then
people are twitching and like taking
more and taking doing Percocet on the
streets and they're all voting Democrats
and they're all voting down and there's
tents on fire and stuff it's just I
actually there's U-Haul trucks U-Haul
ran out of trucks leaving California who
Hall is the moving company all those
orange trucks but it's an American thing
they ran out of trucks to go and buy
people's items outside of the state it's
a failed state that is crazy advice for
anybody listening just get out of
liberal cities as soon as possible but
don't come here
you came here I came here because you
came here it's okay but we're not work
we're not work but they come here and
they get converted no no have you
checked out Austin Texas yeah it's like
liberal yeah because they come here and
they vote the same that's true yeah I
can come here not being really
ridiculous right now but you know what I
mean okay so make sense before you come
here yeah yeah okay add value you know
assimilate okay assimilate become a
republican honor Ronda Sanchez take your
mask off and come hang out with us yeah
another thing I like about Dubai is they
don't allow you to even become a citizen
really you're only you're just
constantly living they favor the
Emirates the people that they favor
favor the ethnic origins of that place
oh how racist which is xenophobic which
is kind of good when you see it because
like it's really well run and they favor
the people who actually live there and
everybody else all the expats who live
there they're there just like using the
city and they they enjoy it and they
enjoy their place they don't complain
about it like it should be equal no I
moved here Dubai like the united in the
Middle East they want to keep it like
Japan they trying to keep it Japanese
same thing that's happening in Ireland
they're saying that it's Ireland's full
they don't want anybody they want nobody
else coming in because immigrants too
many immigrants and if you start to make
everything equal they come here and they
get all arrogant and stuff like that
like we should take over but you're not
providing any solution to replace it
with I guess a little bit of
protectionism protectionism over like
the the culture of the land and the
Norms of the of the land that you're
going to and it started out as a white
country and black people and Chinese
people were building it you know and
maybe that should that essence of it
would keep the country going properly I
mean look we tried the Equal Opportunity
thing and didn't work failed experiment
and we're doing all right none of us
here are white so you know we're doing
all right I'm not really white am I
the white come on I'm Jewish we're not
white Gideon
they actually don't well black people
call you white white people most white
people call you white wokey white people
call you white no at University
no I think we're the same color oh come
on
give me a few weeks wait till I get my
mind once my Miami Tan is on I will be
your color so I could come on
you are I don't know what you are what
are you like half Filipino half like
that's the politically correct term
ethnically ambition no you have like you
have like Philippines you're winning
certain points by the way for being
ethnically ambiguous oh yeah I get to
talk about this stuff like very easily
like it's the subject is perfect for me
to talk about wait but I just want to
say when I went to University so I I was
I wasn't like a Jewish bubble all my
life until I went to University then I
went to University and everyone there
was like white and English and they were
like you're not white yes and I was like
actual white supremacist won't call you
white because they're like oh we need to
be Christian Anglo-Saxon all this stuff
they have all the white pride stuff like
that to walk away people you're white
because to be like it's the same color
yeah well I don't know I mean I just I
just remember calling my dad like really
confused I was like Dad are we white
like like I was like and everyone
everyone's saying that I'm not white I
thought I was white and then everyone
was like looking at me like I was
foreign and I was I was really confused
they're like what percentage of like
English to Jewish are you and I was like
100 both what yeah I was like I don't I
don't know where to go with this like
that that was my University experience
but anyway
so you said you you're going to Japan or
you've been in Japan you're going to
Tokyo yeah I'm going to Japan
um I want to do a show with Ryan Dawson
I think you should speak to him yeah he
would uh he would have a really
interesting conversation he's like one
of the he was the first person to
uncover the Epstein file and and he was
the first person like back in 2000 he
was been on MySpace like that he was
canceled a long time ago uh I think that
you guys would have a good conversation
I think I mentioned you to him
um he said some positive things about
you but yeah I want to go visit him like
how old is he who is he I think he's
like 40 or something like that and he is
has his own he streams on cozy TV
sometimes and uh he has his own website
extreme one of the smartest people uh
that I've ever spoken to geopolitically
okay like extremely aware so I want to
go talk to him and he's been talking a
lot about how
um how Japanese women are much better
than American women interesting did I
tell you the stat yet no tell me guess
how much the average well you only know
kilos right do you know pounds yes I
know pounds what like weight yeah I
guess almost the average American woman
weighs
um so I weigh like eight and a half
pounds Stone I know Stone story I know
Stone we do stone at home is this 400 BC
yeah sweetie Stone what is that in
pounds like 115 pounds
if I say I weigh 115 pounds does that
sound correct yes okay so I weigh 115
pounds so the average average American
Woman
I don't know like 130 114. is that too
low stop stop is it ready for the red
pill oh my God 170.
I'm 115. that's the average guess how
much the average American black woman
weighs
187 180. why is everyone fat here
because the food like you said and also
just the diet the lifestyle what the
promote what the advertising what they
show in Walmart the food portions of
food sizes the lifestyle the stress like
everything just points to being fat as
[__] but in Japan the average woman
weighs 120 pounds and so he said and
then that just seems like this Utopia
away from all this garbage away from
these fat feminist girl bosses who think
like I don't need them just away away
from all that I want to go check it out
and see what another society's like
Dubai was another was a good step away
from the west and seeing an Islamic
culture but there's a lot of people who
are red pill that live in Japan as well
so I would like to see I want to be able
to see more places that are away from
the Western degeneracy
that's good that's good
um I wanted to go back a minute and ask
you about tape because you mentioned the
whole cancer thing and that was um
pretty crazy because I saw that a
Twitter account put out all those like
files and those documents but then a lot
of people close to him
like confirmed on social media that he
had cancer yes I told you I saw I saw he
he wrote like a
um an Instagram thing saying yes
confirmed I was the one that drove him I
saw what's his name Sterling yeah yeah
Sterling he was gonna he said something
so I was confused like but then he says
no yeah I was they were like yeah as
people close to him I knew this I'm like
I never heard about this yeah um so yeah
I guess it was a misunderstanding it
feels like a lot of like this is my take
and you can give me your take tell me
you're wrong I feel like there's a lot
of um The Narrative around Tate it's
being curated
um purposely by those closest to him I
feel like he's in charge and in control
of how he wants the public to perceive
him
that like I feel like he's he's like
driving a certain narrative like he he
knows
like he wants people to be talking about
certain things about him he wants people
to only know certain things about him
like I know you said that he has kids
and a lot of people say he has kids I
still don't I don't know I still don't
know yeah go for it yeah I think
yeah sorry guys yeah later gets very uh
hangry so we've got so we've got her
some Nutella and bread Nutella not a
Nutella I was trying to say it in the
American way okay anyway no I agree I
think Andrew Tate I think he's got a lot
of smoker mirrors around him and there's
a lot of theater around Andrew he will
show you what he wants you to see when
he wants you to see it so it's like he
has cancer oh no no it's been revealed
he doesn't he's like poking the bear
getting reactions seeing how they bite
and then moving forward with it in
whichever way he likes to go he'll show
you he has kids oh no he doesn't have
kids it was Tristan's kids he's putting
out what he wants you to see and he will
react accordingly and do whatever it is
he to do basically do whatever it is he
does I think he's basically a master at
it so you know it's a lot happening I
just don't know why I believe that's all
yeah I mean this is my famous thing this
is what I always say so forget if you're
on the right forget if you're on the
left forget if you love Andrew you don't
love Andrew you love CNN you don't love
CNN whatever it might be I live by my
own experiences so what I see with my
eyes I will confirm but that doesn't
mean you don't need to tell me to not
touch the stove because it's boiling hot
you don't need to tell me that for me to
figure out it's hot but the more
ambiguous things like news or
information that we hear I will live by
my own experience so if I see it I will
confirm it's true but if I haven't seen
it with my own eyes
I just take it as gossip hearsay
innuendo I don't believe it that's my
view okay bye I'll take these I don't
know I just there's just like so much
that I that I don't know until I see
with my own eyes basically yeah I will
I'm not going to speak I'm about that
stuff I never heard about it so yeah I
just want him to I want everybody to
realize that he's innocent and just
can't wait for for them to get out of
jail so that they could finally
keep spreading the positive message that
a lot of us have been impacted by yeah
it's just so it's so crazy that they're
still in jail I I can't believe it and
people are people celebrate it I know so
that's earlier but like people are
literally celebrating it I mean it's
it's pretty big eye-opener if you went
to jail they would celebrate if I went
to jail think about how many people
would be extremely happy if we died
actually that that was something that I
was sitting thinking about like there's
people out there and then you have to
move calculated and then you got to play
chess with all these things you have to
be extremely knowing how many people
are praying on this to on us to fail you
just have to to play it smarter and you
have to carry your image better and just
make sure that you stay positive and you
don't get involved in this in the back
and forth nonsense you can't let them
bring you down to their level because
misery loves company they want you to
fail they want you to die because
they're unhappy and so they need you to
be arguing with them because now you're
on their level now you're equal to them
because you're even engaging in a
conversation with these miserable people
so just I see them for what it is you
asked me earlier about this quite like
these people who wish death who are you
know actually want you like you really
who hate you with all your just let them
be I understand you know you gotta
approach it with empathy and not even in
a patronizing like oh a little girl it's
just I I feel you I mean I've been there
before I've been an unhappy person the
internet leaving Long comments you're
not that person anymore I'm not the type
of to reply to it just let them go they
need that that's their that's their
little bit of happiness at the end of
the day they're they're it's not really
fulfilled they're getting called losers
they don't accomplish their dreams and
goals they don't know why they're are
being programmed to think they're
depressed and there's all these other
things that make them unhappy and so
they're a little bit of dopamine is to
say I hate you and so instead of being
like whoa just let them have it you know
what am I going to change their mind
they would even be
it would they would feel happier if I
engaged them and they had a conversation
but then afterwards like after a day
it'd be even worse because then I'm not
giving him more attention so just I
understand that's a great mentality that
they need that yeah they need that they
need it they need it no that's
interesting because I get so much hate
but I don't look at it anymore I'm like
I just I just I don't care like I just I
just tell my brother like I just I don't
care like we were talking about um
because at the Bitcoin conference coming
up um and Gideon's like ready to like be
on guard in case anyone actually tries
to like attack me whatever and and
guinea was like no they weren't the
worst they'll do is like you know
probably upload a picture with you and
then like trash you online or like a
video with you and then trash you online
they're not gonna come up to you I've
never had anybody come up it's weird you
have people like 10 000 likes I hate
secret with all my heart never seen any
of them I think this and I that really
opened up my eyes to those types of
people because the same people who are
replying to everything and saying they
hate me they probably also came up and
asked for a picture well exactly it's
got to be that way it's got to be their
way of like feeling like they're a part
of it or something like that I have to
think about how many pictures I've taken
at the airport with people who have also
wished death upon me and Scott because
they never come up and say I want you to
die never I've never had any negative
interactions in public no thank God like
creepy guys but not like I hate you no I
only get I get really positive
interactions but like I am I am on God
like I'm very I'm very careful now
yeah I'm very careful it's the women
yeah so women yeah so so Gideon thinks
that I should be more careful of like
the trans women on like South Beach or
something like that because they're
actually men so they could physically
hurt me but because they think that
they're women they think we're on a
level with each other so they're gonna
be like yeah [__] like punch in the
face
like I've said this oh this is better a
hospital
uh all right no I can't even get in
frame but anyway I've said this I've
said this on your story I think I'm not
afraid of the hospital I'm not afraid of
the men for you no man is gonna it's
very rare that a man will come up and
attack you they're gonna be polite maybe
a bit creepy whatever but they're not
gonna ever attack you it's these
feminist women who see what you write
online and they will come up to her and
so there she is and they'll do trickery
deception Street tactics you know like
real Street tactics deceptive stuff oh I
love you hey girl hey all this crap
bang cracker in the face there was a
crackhead looking woman who came up just
the other day I was about to grab later
to move around the way but then I
realized after two seconds it was cool
um unlike the creep this morning but
these are the people you need to be
careful of it's the feminist women it's
the transgender women the blue haired
women they're the ones who feel oh it's
girl on girl come on we're allowed to
fight men it's very rare where they
would ever dare get physically
confrontational with you it's so rare
which is
which is funny because like all these
people hate men so much and I'm like
it's the men who are the nicest yeah
like it's the men who are the who are
the kindest whenever I get approached
because we have to be on guard now it's
just the metoo movement you gotta men
are afraid of saying anything negative
publicly yeah they do just understand
that all this stuff exists only because
social media exists yeah this is where
people get to Let It Go all right so I
want to move on this conversation a
little bit and I want to talk about
social media and Free Speech because you
had this huge platform on YouTube what
did you have like a million you had more
like two million subscribe my main eight
150 on my second so I would say two
million two million total yeah and you
were banned on Twitch as well
feel because you you put so much time
and so much energy into building this
thing I'm sure you obviously made a lot
of money from it so it became like part
of like you know making a living and
just existing and they took that from
you how did that feel
it at first I kind of expected that to
happen but it's been a couple months now
and I I kind of like that it happened at
first there was a moment where I was
looking through my heart I had come back
from London so it happened right after I
was in Bucharest with the tape brothers
and then I went to London he flew and
did a Piers Morgan and I was a shop and
got the email blah blah blah I wasn't
done with a lot of these people and I
didn't really I just kept pushing
forward kept doing podcasts like okay
this will happen but then I'm back in
Miami and I'm looking through my hard
drives trying to find my old videos and
then some of them weren't popping up and
like I called my mom like do you have my
hard drive or whatever I'm just like
looking through all the old memories
like 10 years and I'm just like that hit
me there like all this it felt like lost
memories it's like oh God it felt like
looking through it's like opening up an
old chess
um an old box of your old toys stuff
like that and then there's a lot missing
and it's tarnished that's what it was
like now it's been a couple months I
think it's part of the journey it's just
part of I actually like that it happened
it gives me another layer like another
[__] in my arms yeah it is the badge I
was canceled and I'm still here I'm
still thriving new new chapter new Step
I'm on Rumble you know it adds a level
of mystery it gives me more validity for
everything that I talk about because you
know you said you can't talk about these
things and here's I'm living proof that
you can't
um and I think it's supposed to be more
difficult yeah I have to work three
times harder than my competition on an
alternative platform I have to think
smarter more strategically I like the
challenge and I think that it's a good
step and it's also a signal to any
anybody who's watching this that wants
to speak about what they really want to
speak about and they don't want to be
afraid of cancellation they don't want
to be afraid of getting attacked or woke
mob any of this garbage so just say what
say what you really think don't be
afraid don't let the woke people
pressure you into believing something
that you don't believe in do what your
heart is saying that you should do don't
you don't you can't let them win or it's
going to continue the cycle so hopefully
that inspired somebody and I know it did
and I'm just gonna keep on pushing and
you know I I don't I am not bound by
these mainstream platforms They Don't
Own Me I'm able to as long as I have
access to the internet I'm here I'm not
going anywhere right that's really cool
my thing with a lot of these platforms
though is that they
like Rumble I don't think is
decentralized I just think it's it's
just not part of like it's got its own
service right like it sort of reminds
you of of Elon Musk and starlink you
know it's got its own its own servers
but it's still owned by that individual
and for me personally that concerns me a
little bit because like I love Twitter
right now Twitter so good you know you
can say all these amazing things you can
say there's only two genders and and all
these crazy things oh my God believe
there's only two genders um because Elon
Musk allows that right but like we don't
know what could happen with Elon Musk
like I genuinely believe everybody is
corruptable everybody has a price like I
don't know I don't know what could
happen with Elon Musk I mean he won't
let Alex Jones back right so I'm often
really concerned that these good actors
could potentially become Bad actors
um and like with Rumble for example I
need I need to go down that hole like I
need to yeah and Nick fuences is on
Rumble and uh yeah they're both what if
you like but what if you like had a
falling out with the CEOs or what if you
you I don't know if something happened
or what if I don't know them that well
what if like they became corrupted
everybody is capable of being
compromised yeah anybody can go fly out
to an island slip up and then they get
them on video touching a kid and it's
over right Russell Brand was uh recently
speculating on Joe Rogan about how many
people are actually compromised how many
scientists were compromised I think the
woke people had this misconception that
scientists will always tell the truth a
lot of those scientists and these
leading experts to push these medical
ideas were on the island and if they had
I don't remember what the equation was
but since Epstein's Island was open
there's probably like 30 000 different
people in power and Science and politics
that all went there and got compromised
on camera I hope that's what I'm saying
hopefully Chris Chris please don't go on
an island don't get compromised on video
uh but right now he's not so right so
that's why sorry just say like that's
like my biggest fear and that's why I
really won a decentralized I actually
want a decentralized internet like
desperately that's what I really want
because obviously I just had my video
take Robert video taken down gotta
strike David Ike taken down it's
unbelievable but there's there are a lot
of there are quite a few projects who
are actually decentralized
um but like you said there are a lot of
pump and dumps but there is one project
which I really like I don't know if
you've heard of them they're called
Tommy have you heard of them so they're
basically building a decentralized
internet and there's no CEO there's no
centralized Authority that can go off to
any Island and be compromised or
anything like that they basically have
everything is owned by the community so
they have a decentralized autonomous
organization where people can basically
vote on different things that happen on
the platform and for me I find that so
much more
um makes me feel more comfortable using
a platform like that because there's no
CEO that you can fall out with that can
get compromised that can you know have a
price or whatever it is so I personally
feel a lot more comfortable with
something which actually is
decentralized but you have to be really
careful because in the crypto world
there are projects that pretend to be
decentralized but they're using like
like the AWS the Amazon web servers
um Google and and all this stuff but
they're not actually decentralized but
the thing is you have to be willing to
get involved in crypto and you have to
be willing to actually like try these
new platforms like would you ever be
willing to jump in and of course yeah I
think I'm the one of the perfect type of
influencer to do it yeah but right now
I'm very Rumble focused but yeah of
course of course I am yeah I mean I I
just I'm so excited for something like
that it's it's just I like Rumble and I
like what it's doing but I I don't like
the idea of a CEO I've just
did I just don't trust them yeah and
then also like and also like you you
understand that like with these
different projects and different
companies everybody has a a goal and a
principle and freedom of expression for
example and Freedom of Information I
know is at the heart of Tommy and for me
that makes me comfortable and I don't
have to I don't have to worry about any
CEO going off I don't have to worry
about anything happening that is the
platform and I feel more comfortable in
that I haven't checked it out but I mean
you've
what are they say Django you have my
curiosity oh thank you very much thank
you very much but what do you think of
the future of the internet's going to be
because if we don't adopt actual
decentralized platforms like Tommy net
or whatever it is or something like
Rumble I don't know you know if you
don't if you don't adopt these I feel
like we're gonna go down to this sort of
we're going down like an orwellian route
where the lights are Facebook Google
Amazon they control everything and you
know YouTube for example has YouTube
kids which is just like indoctrinating
the young kids with all this rainbow
indoctrination and it's really dangerous
these three corporations would control
everything so how do you see the future
of the internet
I think that they completely lost their
they lost all their
validity or nobody believes in
mainstream media anymore nobody there's
not one person who who on both sides
nobody actually believes the narrative I
think
most people believe in certain
influencers I think people are going to
look at independent journalists more now
this is what happened in the past three
years more than ever people are going to
look to people that they can relate to
that they are entertained by in order to
get information from it's not going to
be in the hands of just a corporation of
one network of one website people are
going to be more skeptical so it's it's
I think they've effectively
decentralized information as well where
the being so untrustworthy you saw that
Trump started that Trump was that's the
reason he won was it
actively call out the mainstream
programming to call out the news and
nobody can disagree with that so now
that that's happening I think it people
are going to gravitate towards and for
anybody watching that that's what you
should do just try to get information
from different people that you can trust
on a on a more personal level instead of
a network
and one thing which obviously we can't
talk about online which is always being
censored right now but I feel I'm happy
to talk about it is like the Dynamics
between men and women and I know you
talk a lot about that so I kind of want
to have that as like a final topic to
get into
um you talk a lot about how girls are
especially Miami with the and like only
fine girls and and all this stuff so
since we last spoke I'm interested to
know how how is like your take on women
younger you know like I guess not really
Millennials anymore more like gen Z like
how what's your take on how
things are in society right now well I
know what they prioritize
they're all addicted to attention so
I advocate men to go their own way mgtow
we call it online just focus on your
purpose on what you're supposed to do
and let them stumble across you know if
they do and try to find a wife I don't
think it's it's worth investing too much
time into that garbage or I think casual
sex is a giant distraction of course
you're gonna need to do it guys need to
to get that out of their system a little
bit but the Curious put the Curiosity to
the side for the most part focus on what
you should be doing and then everything
else is going to fall into place I think
I understand most gen Z women now if
they're addicted to tick tock which they
pretty much all are then they're going
to be addicted to attention if they're
going to be addicted to attention
they're going to prioritize their
appearance over trying to find love and
you can hear them talk on all these when
you really dissect what they say they
all say pretty much the same thing they
have the same belief systems they're not
that interesting so I don't want to
waste my time with them the only time I
spend going on dates now and I see it as
a I see it as I go into the gym to spar
I just do it to train myself like in
Dubai when like three or four dates and
I'm just in there like navigating like
bobbing and weaving with the [__] test
what kind of women you go on dates with
oh Dubai there were oh they were just
garbage buy what made them garbage
they're I mean so they're in Dubai and
there's a lot of money around and so
they
there are a lot of them are corrupted so
they've moved there because one they had
a boyfriend that moved them out there
and then they broke up because they
thought they were going to be a girl
boss they have daddy's money and so they
don't want to be daddy's money girl so
they invent a career in their head about
I'm a real estate agent and they're just
going around like I'm in a business
meeting who says business meeting just
go to the meeting like they're telling
you like this is and they're wearing
like a suit but they're not really
making any you're making all your money
from your dad like stop trying to put on
this thing to go and compete so that you
could be like oh this I'm interested
you're not interesting no one cares
about your career we don't but it's just
navigating I'm like learning these
things about the tactics and trying to
get around that these women are just
just dumb there's so much money in Dubai
that a lot of women they don't want to
submit they don't want to like
relinquish their power so they're
they're competing with the guy they're
on a date with but guys guys aren't
competing with the girls just want to
like spend time with a girl these girls
are just like I'm also interesting and
have a career and this is this is shut
up but how old are these girls my age
like 23 24. yeah I was going on and
you know you try to and also there's the
the Muslim things so they're trying to
like not I'm not easy like okay but
you're also not good at having
conversation so pick one you know don't
be prude and also be terrible at having
conversations because now you're just a
waste of space
otherwise you're just like I'm taking
you out to dinner and you're just being
a for no reason oh man go away but I got
I got pretty good I went in on three
dates and I got pretty good at
navigating the [__] test and stuff like
that and learning more about what kind
of [__] test did they did they give you
so when women have a bad relationship
they will put it on the next guy and as
if it's like you're like they'll blame
men for a failed relation like you think
like oh yeah well he was you think that
I'm gonna be that and I'm like what what
do you mean like oh you think I'm like
easier I didn't nice to meet you you
know yeah I had this girl get in the car
I said maybe like three senses after
like getting her on Instagram
um and tell her to come through and
she's in the car in the back seat and
she says I hope you know I'm not having
sex with you tonight I didn't even talk
to you yet wow like I'm not like one of
these other girls so what that was is
she probably got cheated on her her
ex-boyfriend probably just slept around
with other girls and she has this idea
that girls are easy and she's not like
those other girls she's trying to feel
better than the other girls that she's
around but that but the men did that to
her that's not well then it's not my
fault either right right why am I
suffering because you couldn't maintain
a relationship you know it's I I
understand it's a what I don't care
whose fault it was I'm taking you out to
a nice dinner [__] off with your
nonsense you know that's what I was like
just okay but a lot of guys so she'll
have a lot of [__] test barriers so
she's testing there if I got angry I got
emotional like what do you you're not
gonna show you I was just like um don't
worry
I don't wanna I'm not that easy either
like yeah that's a good response right
like you need to take that on three days
and she goes haha she was just testing
mentally because she has all these
blocks and you just need to be able to
stay stoic when she's being a [__] yeah
and just Bob and weave her bitchiness
and just not get and then she ended up
the next day she sent me an apology
video because she texted me like thanks
for tonight after she was being a [__]
yeah um when she I called her the taxi
to go home she's like I hope he you know
it's my job to make your life difficult
she said that to you word for word
before she got in the cab word for word
and I'm like okay
bye you know I didn't do anything just
buy you know so and then the next day
she says thanks for dinner and then I
don't respond she says you're welcome
sarcastically and then she sent me an
apology video like
sorry my ex-boyfriend was really toxic
and now I'm like I have all this baggage
and she's 23. so it just shows like how
quickly women can become corrupted by a
pair bonding the wrong way being in a
relationship where she had the wrong
intentions she's there with the Blazer
on trying to be a business girl and
she's just doing amazes so much she's
she's trying to be Hillary Clinton like
what are you what are you doing yeah
she's doomed for failure she's not going
to realize this until she's 35 with a
bunch of cats and then she's gonna be
like maybe I should have been nice when
this guy took me out to a nice
restaurant in Dubai but it is what it is
you just realize like
I I find that entertaining to just see
female nature for what it really is and
how women can get corrupted and also to
strengthen my ability to not get
emotional and to stay stoic in
situations like that when she like so
we're out to dinner and all these girls
are having a fun time they're dancing
and she's like in the just texting like
all this stuff and I'm like this why
like why are you being unpleasant but
just breathe it's fine
and then towards the end a couple days
later uh
I got my revenge what did you do I got
what I wanted uh okay yeah well done so
but that would not have happened if I
wasn't unmatched perspicacity
makes me a feared opponent in any realm
a few minutes Bob and weave the [__]
test that's all you got to do I like it
what are some of the green flags that
you look for
good conversation
um happy friendly well-dressed
and
yeah I would say like like you present
yours the way you present yourself
online are a lot of green flags like I'm
I'm surprised I'm surprised that there
hasn't that you're not married that's
yeah that's my synopsis there's nobody
that I like enough yet because your
standards are high your standards are
very look at the way Gideon's here like
no stay back
yeah no I need that that's that's tough
yeah
yeah you can you see this
all right oh [__] I don't think that um
hello testing one two three I don't
think that you've ruined
as my sister I think that Leia is very
competent I think that she's a very
competent individual obviously she's
very intelligent as well wonder where
she gets all that from
like that you do
you do [__] he literally need to set
that line anyway but the point is what
the [__] that's good what the [__] but
my point my point is I think that yeah
she is comforting and intelligent all
that kind of stuff so yeah and as we
know in this kind of like you know how
men and women are in reality women
obviously go upwards you know they want
someone better and I guess worst case
scenario
um equal but like you know Leia you know
not equal women women worse I know I'm
saying worst case equal okay until the
divorce happens ten five six years later
right okay but like yeah exactly so they
want you know someone a lot better and
Leia wants someone a lot better and
obviously as we know oh sorry they're
just spitting you I'm sorry but as we
obviously as we know oh I'm sorry but as
we know you know like these kind of men
they're not they're not everywhere
they're less than one percent they're
called one percent men or whatever you
want to call it for a reason you know
they're not every day walking on the
street where like this is a great way to
tell you to show to illustrate how
there's so many beautiful women for men
to choose from I'm saying this to this
girl I was hanging out with the other
day you know you could let's say you're
hanging out with a girl called I don't
know Natasha you could say to her I'll
show you that there's a gajillion other
than thank you there's a gajillion other
natashas who are beautiful you could
literally say I'll type Natasha in on
Instagram and I'll watch what comes up
they'll like be a gajillion natashas
click on them the top ones with big bomb
boobs everything like there's a hundred
others for me to choose from go try find
another me it's very difficult so and
obviously you know you want to get it
right as a woman and like Leia
understands that you don't want to mess
around with different men you just spoke
about a 23 year old woman who has a lot
of baggage because she's not picking
right is she she was with some toxic
person or whatever that person was I
think that guy was fine they were
engaged apparently yeah she was saying
all this stuff they're engaged and she
probably just got too much pride and she
wanted to be equal she wanted to be like
I'm also an earner and then she just got
like I'm this I I think the career thing
got in the way and her ego did women are
egotistical because of social media yeah
they they think that they need to do the
things that men do in order to earn
status but women don't understand that
no one cares about your status as a
woman it's like your feminine quality
are you do you have good energy are you
Pleasant to be around are you beautiful
that's what matters I don't care about
your career nobody does you're only
trying to impress yourself and other
women
finally I think I'm in the frame yeah I
wasn't in afraid but no you're
absolutely right let's listen whether
that 23 year old woman she you know she
had something good going for I don't
know maybe but the point is a lot of
women as we know they get they pick up
bad baggage like you were like you were
saying so like it's very important that
Leia picks correctly because otherwise
yeah you you know you don't want to get
into that situation and that's hard yeah
women when they go through I want to
rush things when women have bad
experiences it makes them worse people
they that's why it's important to have
somebody that can protect you from stuff
like that and when some blue hair guy is
like let me debate her I'm like don't
yeah I love that you did that because I
feel like I just I don't know that's
good that's nice like no let's leave
later she doesn't need your energy it's
not gonna be good it's just don't do it
uh you you need that but for men like
that's why I go on these terrible dates
because then it doesn't make me I'm not
like it's like oh I understand why it
makes me be able to navigate this better
in the future understand more when men
go when I get canceled that makes me
better because I'm like it gives you
more mental strength it gives you more
stamina it makes you a more competent
person to go through hardship women just
makes you worse um
yeah it's a good point yeah yeah so
that's why it's very important Leia
doesn't just settle for any like there's
loads of men like you know loads of men
ask me and I'm like sure yeah speaker
you know like but she doesn't want any
of them because she sees like ah he's
not this he's not that and like it's
like maybe it's if it's oh I earn more
money than you or if it's like you're
you know you've had the the Jib Jab and
I haven't had the Jib Jab so she's like
if if I ca if I can withstand having the
JibJab like why can't you as a [__]
man it's like why can't you do it why'd
I have to be with someone who gets
tricked and fooled by the government
yeah I don't like how does that how does
that make you better than me like I want
someone who's better like so it's tough
but like I think you know you just got
to can I say something that happened and
pick it and pick one recently I think
Sonny told me about the Sonny works in
the creativity kid he said that um you
guys went out to dinner and maybe you
can cut this out if you want me to bring
it up but you had one on a date and then
you were not responding or something
like her location was messed up oh oh oh
good wait who's Sunny said this yeah
well he said that in confidence
it's okay it's okay it's okay
but that's a true story so continue what
you were saying and I'll elaborate on
the story
damn I just called him out a rat no no
son no all good Sunny we love Sunny
we're gonna do a collab with sunny okay
so he said uh you were on a date right
before you went to dinner yeah and then
your your location was responding and
then you were just like I'm gonna go
call the cops and you were like looking
at the location freaking out okay okay
what happened was so yeah Leia went on a
date with this really cool guys a nice
guy said sure you should ask my sister
out and very cool guy anyway the point
is I asked of course I say Leia put your
location services on so I can see
exactly where you are and so I I can see
anyway the point is especially because
Gideon set up the date so I was on the
date because of Gideon so now Gideon is
entirely responsible for whatever
happens to me continue you could say
that exactly exactly anyway the point is
I always say look just text me where you
are let me know when you get in the car
let me go to the restaurant whatever it
is and I see and I knew and I knew where
they were going but I see him go in a
completely different direction on the
location I see
supposed to be going south and I was
going directly north up the highway for
like a good 20 minutes yeah so she's
going up the highway for a good whatever
I don't know 10 20 minutes and I'm like
where the [__] are they going this is
not where they're going this is really
weird so you know I'm maybe they're
going a difference he chose to go to a
different restaurant no problem so I'm
calling Leia to confirm this what's the
deal I'm texting she's not answering so
I and I'm out for dinner yes with sunny
my friend at um satire whatever it's
called and I'm like I said to guys I
gotta go and I'm about to leave the
dinner I'm about to call the cops and
I'm about to show them the phone and say
we're chasing after this person right
now let's go and he's about to throw off
at the same time yeah yeah and I'm also
about to yeah I'm obviously my heart is
panicking I'm like [__] you know what
the hell's going on anyway finally after
about what five calls she answered it
was six calls and said no I'm absolutely
fine and I'm so sorry and I said I was
this close to calling the cops and doing
a [__] Michael Bay chase scene down
[__] whatever Highway it is in Miami
why were you not answering
I was having a great time now I'm joking
my phone was just on silent um my phone
basically so if I'm like out even with
friends but if I'm on a date with a guy
like I make sure that my phone's away
like I don't want to come across as one
of those women because imagine we're
having a conversation I'm just here like
yeah that was the day that I went on
yeah right so if I'm out with a man my
phone is away like it's very for me I
find really disrespectful like even with
fun with a girlfriend and she's on her
phone I will stop speaking while she's
staring at her phone and then when she
wants to look back up I will then be
like okay I'll continue now like I just
find it disrespectful so my I just I
don't know my phone's in my in my bag
and to be fair the reason we went up
north was to get um gas for the car
because and it was the only station that
was open 20 minutes north yeah
everything was shot for some reason I
don't know and so like for a good 20
minutes which is up the highway and my
phones are silent and so yeah Gideon's
like having a heart attack and uh and
then I DM the guy as well and then he
writes to me after layer called me like
yeah it's all good bro and then I think
also he might have got offended because
I then said later on in the night I
wrote to him saying I know I wrote to
Leia saying all good and I think he saw
the WhatsApp they were at the restaurant
at the time after and he was like yeah
it's all good like I'm a cool guy and
like but listen bro here's the thing if
you're getting offended by the brother
saying all good and constantly checking
on checking in it's like come on chill
out like you know how it is man to man
you know what the deal is so I found
that kind of weird that could be a
potential red flag like I'm the [__]
brother you know what the deal is it's
like there's this scene in billions you
know do you ever watch the the series
billions it's with uh Daniel day no
what's the American always Damian Lewis
with Damian Lewis anyway anyway the wife
the wife's kind of left him and he goes
to the brunt she goes to the brother
anyway he so Bobby Axelrod in the series
billions goes storming he's like this
big billionaire powerful man he goes
storming to the brother's house to find
his wife and the brother is like no I'm
not telling you where she is and then
they get into this kind of fight and but
but Damien Lewis Bobby asks where the
character goes you're a good brother for
doing that you're good see as a man he
gets it he sees he's protecting the
woman that's what you should do so for
him to be like this was weird the
brother was saying all good I'm not a
creep and he got offended it's like come
on man like you know how it is man to
man how did you vet him for the date
how to dive in for the day well one of
the main things is JibJab obviously
JibJab is obviously a good determinate
determiner of like you know how his
character is yeah
yeah I like he he like looked physically
physics strong and I know that sounds
like a really shallow surface level
thing to say but it's actually not
because like this guy was like in great
shape so though so to us it's like okay
this is a man who clearly takes personal
responsibility he's clean not lazy he's
clearly very determined like in order to
look like that you've got to be on it
like you've got to yeah you this man has
discipline he takes personal
responsibility he's strong he's
masculine like cool let's find out what
he does let's speak with him so that's
what Gideon did and um where'd you find
him
we can't give away too much information
it's the worst thing we know about it I
mean this whole red pill Community talks
about all the time with women how you
know women get uh you know they're with
one guy maybe they like them and then
something happens and that they just
carry that baggage to the next
relationship and it's just spewing out
and she's never the same and all this
kind of stuff so it's very important
that you get it right and if that means
you're not going on loads of dates and
sleeping like so be it good you stay at
home you do it until you feel like you
have the right person protect your
energy absolutely you know where and
that's the problem with most women in
today's world right they like like you
said earlier they think they're equal to
men they think they can sleep around
they think they can wear the Blazers I'm
doing the business meeting they think
they can act like men but in actual fact
I said this to you the other day it's
just Unbecoming on a woman you know it's
Unbecoming it's unattractive it doesn't
suit you you are not designed born that
way no one wants to see you like that
it's unattractive the same way you know
the girls who I've been with wouldn't
want to see me in [__] high heels or
you know in a dress or talk about how
I've got my nails manicured or or pay
more attention to whatever's going on in
my closet and all the clothes I've got
look at it you know they wouldn't care
like why this guy likes shoes more than
me or he does his nails better than me
or he has more problems than me this is
like but people are just so yeah but
women don't even really care about women
are told to not care about what men want
it's it's seen as oppressive to go and
fit the male gaze like I'm not gonna go
follow the male beauty standards they
think that they are fighting the
patriarchy by not shaving their armpits
by being uglier by shaving off their
hair by adding a bunch of flags to their
bio look at all the places I've traveled
I'm gonna go I'm an independent girl
boss Queen they're they're they're
fighting against the system because I'm
not oppressed I could do what I want I
keep I I'm fighting the system that's
what they actually think it doesn't it
doesn't matter even even us saying that
it doesn't make a difference yeah
I'm just gonna just one sneaker while I
say yeah I mean listen women are just
women are just so this is what I like to
I think I said to lay the other day
women have outpriced themselves
women have outpriced themselves well
think about it what does it mean to out
price yourself in the marketplace they
are there was a girl in the gym I looked
at her the other day when I was working
out and
she I could just tell they're the guy
that's gonna ask her out that she will
eventually like and you know respect and
stuff like that he's gonna be an
exceptionally competent man because
women now coming into the workplace in
the last 50 60 years things they're told
by the media they hear uh Mega pastalian
they hear uh all these women
they hear all these people and they're
like spice ice I don't even know what
that is but spice ice they hear these
people and they think oh I can do this I
can do that and I can sleep around and I
can be like a man and you know whether
it's like sexually sleeping around or
whether it's like earning money like a
man you the woman out prices herself so
much so that there's no more men left no
one and then the man wouldn't even want
to put up with you in the first place
why would you want to put up with that
kind of woman anyway it's gonna take so
much masculine energy to knock her back
into her feminine that it's like I deal
with so much crap all day why do I have
to come home and deal with this why it's
like I don't have time for it and it's
like I'm doing my part as a man and it's
like I think you should do your part as
a woman and it's like people make me
think this is you know sexist this is
old school this is you know you sound
like my grandpa but listen this has been
working for what thousands and thousands
of years okay it doesn't mean in the
last 56 years due to the invention of
contraception that suddenly we can flip
everything the other way and pretend it
won't last and it doesn't work and it
takes you down a very dark place
in terms of how Society evolves it would
evolve for the worse you know and
there's other theories like tyranny and
stuff like that Leia speaks about a lot
but it's not good
it's good good yeah okay that's very
good thank you so much thank you
well I was just gonna say about like you
know women being in their feminine and
you know the patriarchy and all this
rubbish is that and they're actually
really nice
like I like men are actually a guy yeah
you're a pretty good guy thanks man like
they're like I am too yeah you're right
no but like in like men are nice like
I've like men do nice things for women
who are nice like a perfect example was
when you didn't want Destiny to debate
me it's just like nah let me just
protect her like you owe me nothing yet
you just as a man wanted to be nice and
protect me in that in that way like the
way men want to help you know are like
uh like if he fancies you there's
nothing wrong with a few fancies you
know I'll help you move I'll help you
pick up your stuff like and it's not
like he's not like now you owe me sex no
he's just like if he gets it well done
he won if he doesn't whatever on to the
next like men just like men just do nice
things and so for me I don't know why
women remember that you're around
because there's a lot of insults look of
course I think there's bad people bad
people exist right but I hate the idea
of women having to compete with men and
I refuse to what was it called the male
gays like rise to the male gaze or
whatever that phrase right appeal yeah I
refuse to appeal to the male gays and I
won't shave my armpits and I'll get rid
of everything that's feminine like why
just be pretty cooking it just cook him
a nice meal he'll be really lovely to
you oh it's so true that's all I want
listen I just want a woman who every day
will make look I'll go do the work don't
worry I'll I'll pull in the money don't
worry about that baby girl like all I
want is bacon eggs some fruit some steak
chicken breasts
bananas I like bananas every day that's
all I need sure yes salt pepper give it
some flavor that's all I need that's all
I want that's all you have to do you
don't have to do this whole I'm a man
act no one wants that no no men like
I've said to lay a million times no man
of real value of substance who's working
every day and knows he's competent
enough to do things on his own sure he
can ask you for advice no men would no
man would want a woman like that so for
any women watching this just listen all
you have to do it's really simple just
just be a woman if you know what that is
no one knows what it is anymore though
the bar is real and the bar is so low
and you'll be surprised that's the real
question women should be asking
themselves we had this debate in the
Cigar Lounge the other night with sunny
actually with this the girl remember
it's like the question women should be
asking is how do I retain a high value
man that's the question how do I do that
as a woman and how do I make him so come
to me first in the first instance and
keep him coming back to me and me only
he's like damn this girl is so good you
know what I don't want to go cheat on
other girls I I don't wanna I don't want
to go see that girl tonight I like I got
this one at home she's really good she
cooks the best food for me she does my
washing my clothing my ironing she
massages me when I come like whatever it
might be she treats me like a king that
I am that's the question women should be
on how do I do that how do I keep him
coming to me instead of all this like oh
but he cheated on me I wanna it's just
that's all crap you're going down the
wrong route you know you just need to
understand how do I be a woman how do I
be how do I tap into my feminine energy
and for that I don't know listen to her
there's other women out there I don't
know
there's not many women out there there's
there's absolutely on Twitter
[Music]
there's not there's no female podcast
maybe this is the only one but the only
female podcasts that are out there
ex-porn stars or female rappers and
they're just they hit the wall and then
they're like you need to be a [__] too
so that I feel better about being a
[__] and men are toxic for demanding a
woman that isn't that doesn't have 300
bodies and isn't on camera getting
[__] you're toxic you're an insecure
man if you you just can't put up with me
it must be insecure if you can't see me
sucking dick on camera like can we have
any sort of Standards anymore or is that
oppressive but we need more women to
have the cyberpunk but oh it's almost
impossible to do that if you don't have
a Gideon behind the scenes protecting
that because a woman on her own doing
that it's going to be CR the comments is
it's gonna be it's impossible without it
and also because I wanted to tell you
about it I was telling Gideon I wanted
you to finish I was like wait that's a
very good point that's a very good point
actually what sneaker just said no I
just want to make that point also you
know like men are so important in
women's lives I think every I said this
to Leia a few times I think every woman
you know growing up you know as she
turns into a teenager whatever it goes
in her 20s needs to have some sort of
masculine role model some kind of
masculine older figure it doesn't even
have to be her father it could be an
older brother it could be an uncle it
could even be Uncle Bob next door you
know that's kind of creepy that's
actually kind of weird but you go away
but you get my point it could be like
some kind of um
family friend I don't know just someone
who who is filling that void that
clearly the woman needs to show the
masculine way and guide her in the
correct direction because women just
don't know they just don't know they
need it I think that I would be very
different if it wasn't for Gideon like
for sure I was like a might like a
little bit of a feminist when I was
younger I was like when I was like 19 20
22 it changed at 23.
yeah yeah yeah I was a bit of a feminist
a little bit not not like crazy but I
was definitely like you know I don't
want to like I I felt like proud you
know I felt like if I if I make my own
money I was like that I'm really proud
you know it didn't come from a place of
like I don't like men or I'm competing
with men it wasn't like that it would
have lovely Brothers of course I love
men like I have no issue with men but
it's more like it was more like you know
I like
I'm a hard worker and I'm proud of that
you know that that's what it that's what
it came from it's not bear feminists no
not really yeah
yeah I I just I just yeah I just felt
like
yeah I didn't understand the value of of
being a mother perhaps right compared to
making your own money like be looking I
guess when I was like 1920 I would look
at stay-at-home moms and be like you
don't do anything right like how are you
proud I felt that too it you see you see
what I mean so so it's not like feminist
is I think it's just a lack of maturity
and and understanding because like now
like oh wow like now I look at mothers
as like like superheroes superheroes and
also I also think um the stay-at-home
mom is so lucky like people really um
undervalue that like the stay-at-home
mom she gets to be in dresses all day
like like on a on cloud nine and like
cooking and being sweet and being nice
like she gets to do all these like fun
things like yesterday I was making
muffins right
and Gideon was getting really annoyed
with me because he wanted to do these
emails and I was making muffins and I
was so happy making these muffins I was
like I was like oh okay now I just like
measure the protein and now I'm gonna
put like a little bit of water and
banana and I'm like literally just up in
the area and Gideon's like Leia can you
stop it like like what did you like he's
like she's in I said she's in mode where
she's just like making muffins and not a
care in the world I was like we got
[__] emails to do this that we need
to work we gotta work we've got to take
over we've got to do what we got to do
and I'm like oh I think they're trying
to kick us out all right we'll be we'll
be five minutes
okay yeah we've hit five because they
don't want us to have these
conversations
yeah but this place is woke you you said
about the the rainbow flag there's a
rainbow flag in the at the front I don't
think we should support this business
anymore but all right I think being a
stay-at-home mom is a privilege and we
should value that sneaker where can
people find you and follow you plug
yourself quick rumble.com Nico and if
you want to learn from me I have lessons
once a week in the creativity kit along
with my other professors that teach
wealth Creations online Sony's in there
I've been uh hired him I think he's just
gonna come on full time but there's a
lot of different professors and you can
find me on Twitter and Instagram at
sneako uh to unlock Twitter all day long
it's very fun I've been posting my old
videos and stuff like that so you can
find me there and yeah Rumble every day
guys follow snico he is super bass doing
some amazing things leading the way in
this crazy crazy world so sneak I want
to thank you so much for coming on it's
been a pleasure I know it's a lot of
energy he's amazing no no he's actually
amazing he's the nicest yeah he comes
across like super like this but he's
like he's he's a nice guy all right
we're going to get overcharged for this
guy I mean I'm a nice guy come on over
charge
all right guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed it please
follow snico he is doing some incredible
things he's on rumble on Twitter so give
him a follow if you like this kind of
content I'm going to be bringing you a
lot more of it so don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe and we'll
see you all next week bye bye